today the subject is male it's scheduled
for roughly one month before the mauling
presidential elections but as many of
you are already aware that is very much
in question now whether the elections
are going to take place and what
electoral politics what politics in
general and sort of what what the
political future from ollie is in the
very near term and what some of the
ramifications for that are going to be
so we have a very distinguished panel
who I think they will distinguish
themselves further when you realize that
we all had things prepared that have
since been furiously rewritten I think
I've been talking to most these people
for quite some time over the past couple
days and quite some volume trying to
figure out what's going on and hopefully
we can figure this out maybe a little
bit more through the talks and through
particularly the questions and answers
and discussion afterwards so I just like
to introduce the panel in general
starting at the north end of the table
is Susanna wing who is a professor of
political science at haverford college
and works on modeling political parties
and electoral democracy in Mali
particularly after nineteen ninety one
in the third republic of Mali and
looking at some of the deeper historical
roots certainly and how those ideas are
mobilized in Mali in politics maybe not
of today but certainly of last week next
to her we have Jamie black who is coming
to us as a professor of also political
science at the University of Notre Dame
in South Bend and she is again a
political scientist working on Molly
particularly sort of popular opinions
about the state and popular engagement
in nacho
electoral politics but sort of political
discussion and political debate between
the everyday citizens and answer the
politics of the street and politics of
the courtyard and the politics of the
courthouse and the politics of the
presidential palace next to Jamie we
have professor Mancha jawara from NYU
who may not need any introduction but he
is a well-known author a scholar of arts
and cinema and literature a filmmaker in
his own right we will be showing his
movie bamako CD come immediately after
this and I believe in this room and he
will be the moderator for the panel and
next to him is chick or trial ray who is
coming to us from Mali after a very
arduous trip and somewhat uncertain
circumstances of how you can actually
get around Molly during the coup as it's
going on so we're very glad that he's
here and he is the president of cosa di
which is a union and interest group of
railroad workers both actively employed
and actively unemployed and a advocacy
agency an advocacy group that relays
sort of challenges some of these
neoliberal policies that we've seen put
in place the Third Republic and
particularly under our today's
presidency i'ma do to monitor ed still I
believe the constitutionally recognized
president of Mali and particularly this
was this was a project that came to life
in the wake of the 2003 privatization of
the Dakar nijiya railroad so there's
going to be a little bit of senegalese
politics as well in this and we
congratulate Senegal on their successful
elections yesterday and so next to
shakira is mohamed seck is that who I
just met and it seems like a really
wonderful guy
and he will be translating for chekura
and he is from Senegal and there
anything else on here with Jamie bugger
as surprise great well welcome my name
is Brandon County I am a historian
finishing my PhD here at Columbia
teaching at Barnard College and I work
on political history of Mali and Senegal
in the 20th century so I'd like to
welcome you on behalf of the panel and
on behalf of is and global thought and I
think we're going to start with Susanna
think that in fact what I would say the
failure of the politics of consensus and
the frustration that arose from this
lack of real opposition and the
frustration on the part of the people
around that the reality of the politics
of consensus which was essentially to
undermine any political dialogue that
had taken place in the 90s even though
it was very contested but there was
political dialogue in the 90s and I
think that really shifted under tha so
that would be the first point that I
would emphasize is that the
ramifications of the politics of
consensus the second point about how
Molly got to where we are today in this
crisis is is the crisis in the north and
that is the combination of the mnla the
you Tuareg rebels rebels who were who
are pushing for the independent state of
Azawad and that in conjunction with the
al-qaeda and islamic maghreb activities
in the north a couple points there one
that i see this crisis as being
particularly pertinent in the sense that
in the mid 90s there was what is called
the problem of the north it's often
referred to as the problem of the north
which was the touareg uprising that
ended with the flub de la Paix in 1994
and one of the key components of
resolving this conflict was
decentralization it was an agreement to
have real decentralization across the
state and what we saw was a shift while
i should say the creation of over 700
municipalities across the state as a
response to the fact that in the north
those who were who the Tuareg rebels in
the north at the time were aggravated
and pushing for increased development in
the north and saying us that they were
sort of had not been included in the
state
and so decentralization was a logical
and important response to that so that's
mid-90s here we are at 2012 and what is
the reality of decentralization well
lack of resources it hasn't been as
effective as one would hope there have
been the local elections successfully
held multiple times which is a plus but
I think also the municipalities have
been bound in some ways by a lack of
resources actually reaching these these
municipalities so I would say the
failure of not complete failure don't
use that word that the challenges of
decentralization and the reality of the
North continuing to be excluded in terms
of real development and the frustrations
around that that combined with I think
what many people in this room probably
know is the reality of Qadhafi's fall
and the return of touareg from Libya
armed to the teeth and now able to push
for demands and the creation of the mnla
as a as a response so so we have I think
if you look at the press now you see a
lot of many comments about the the
humiliation of the military the
frustration of the military in the North
who don't have enough did not have
essential food and equipment in order to
to face the the armed MNLA and the
destabilization of the UN has reported
this is prior to the coup the UN
reported over 200,000 refugees or
internally displaced persons in Mali
200,000 so and that's a direct result of
this activity of of the MNLA so that
crisis was obviously getting worse by
day by day and making the question of
whether or not these elections were
actually going to be able to be held
and effectively in the end of April and
the government was adamant that yes
indeed there would be without a doubt
presidential elections at the end of
April to be combined with a
constitutional referendum and and the
government was standing very firm while
I think many people were saying how can
this take place effectively across the
country when we now have 200,000
refugees so that's the second the second
point again and the third about how
Molly came to this place growing
frustration with with corruption is very
clear and I think that not everyone is
surprised by this coup I have some
points I wanted to I'll share with you
from somebody who I have been
communicating with who is actually pro
coup and supports this situation and so
so but but a very widespread frustration
with corruption amongst the political
class and finally the the general I
would say the general nature of
political parties in Mali has also
contributed to where we are today and
that is that the frustration on the fact
that of many of these political parties
don't really stand for much they are
they are entities around personalities
right and and so what is it what our
citizens voting for when they're not
voting for political platforms they're
voting for people who say they stand to
against corruption and they would like
to see the they would like to see
poverty reduced in the country and they
would like to see an end to corruption
etc so so I think the nature of
political parties has contributed to
precisely where we are today in Mali and
and a few I guess what I'd like to do is
share with you some some comments that
have been made to me by by a contact
that I have in Mali who is a former
judge and who has been who
has been who's basically said here here
are the reasons that I and many others
are supporting this coup and the sort of
the texts that we're putting together
about what needs to happen now is to
first negotiate clear conditions between
the political class and civil society
for a transitional government that has a
clear mandate that is very precisely
laid out through some sort of
legislative organ that will be created
and the mandate will be articulated
around first negotiating the conditions
for a return to peace in the north well
throughout the entire country and again
absolutely non-negotiable that this is
one country and divisi blue and and that
Molly will not let its borders be be
changed and a complete should have
translated this an assessment of the
entire administration both civil and
military with respect to corruption
nepotism etc and making sure that all
the electoral lists are clear and fair
and in fact creating the electoral cards
in the biometric biometric electoral
cards which there's been a lot of talk
about doing and then finally proceeding
to free fair transparent and democratic
elections and I want to say this is
somebody who was very much involved in
the 1991 coup and participated in then
the transition government and the
conference Nacional etc who then over
time got extremely frustrated with the
direction that that politics took under
at tts so I think I don't want to go any
longer but just to say that those those
are sort of the key places of how we got
to where we are and and I think what
people are seeing hopefully as as as a
way forward and that is a transitional
government and and elections being held
as soon as possible
the views of my time might be to speak
of it to the Malian populations
perception of elections and what
elections can actually be I feel like a
lot of what we're going to talk about
today will not be so much about formal
electoral channels as much as informal
power and contentious politics so I just
wanted to say a word on Elections before
they get swept off the table and and
complicate elections by offering sort of
two contradictory statements about them
in Gregory man's most recent post on the
Molly and COO today he discussed the
widespread sentiment of politicking mine
which essentially means politics are bad
right so in Mali usually when we speak
of poly Tiki were speaking directly of
elections and election cycles and
candidates it's sort of this very narrow
understanding of political action and I
just I thought I'd give you some quotes
of people that I've been talking to in
the last year the first is a village
leader he's in a village not far from
Walesa boo boo if any of you know where
that is about an hour and a half from
Bamako and his his take on the upcoming
sort of color to watch e which refers to
the electoral campaigning period versus
normal time and how the shapes sort of
everyday mullins relationships with
political parties was to say I thought
rather eloquently we're nothing but fish
to them to the political parties they
come to our village during the campaigns
and they cast their nets once they reel
in their catch their work is done so we
see a very sort of skeptical take on
formal politics here and the skepticism
is an uncommon I'll just give you two
more quotes from people from survey work
that I've done with a team of
researchers in Mali the first is a man
from su casa and he's about 20 years old
and he said everything that's related to
politics and molly is dishonest it's to
fill pockets and to get out a woman in
her 50s living in Mopti she had a
similar sentiment of I don't like
politics it's nothing more than pure
lies so there are even harsher critiques
of the judicial branch where many Molly
and see laws that cater to the rich and
powerful and connected and the rural
voter might be described
detached from these democratic
institutions but the narrative from
within Bamako right now I think points
to visible corruption and an economic
market where who you know in high places
determines your job prospects and
futures for the sort of the fortunes of
your own private enterprise so despite
the skepticism I think it's extremely
important to highlight some enduring
aspects of Mali and democracy that are
threatened by the current coup first off
I'd like to say that in doing a surveys
of a thousand Mullins and Timbuktu
psychosomatic I bamako molins know the
rules of the game they know their
democracy they own their democracy
they're very proud of it so when for
instance we gave a political pop quiz on
our survey seventy percent of
respondents could named executive term
limits I challenge our American
population to named executive term
limits at such a high a high rate but
when when people did it they did it the
same way and they said you know sam
gutelle Shan flah five years two times
in a row and and this was I was
connecting these surveys in 2009 and
this was during Tania's you know
constitutional coup in New Year and a
lot of moly ins boasted well compared to
that that could never happen here in
Mali so secondly I wanted to point out
that despite the perceived flaws that I
described earlier elections shouldn't be
written off as mere democratic theatre
when I was in Mali in January there was
an active debate about the 2012
elections and there was no agreement
about who is going to win at that time
people were discussing which candidate
maybe not because of the program that
they offered but maybe more based on
their sort of personal character what's
best place to deal with the issues of
the North would be the strongest sort of
combatant against corruption and so this
was an important debate that was
happening and you know going to rural
communities I spoke with a lot of people
who are defiantly saying you know salt
and sugar isn't going to cut it anymore
that handouts don't bring sustainable
development so elections are more than
just going through the Democratic
motions right they trigger they trigger
societal reflection about what Molly's
should be and about the mechanisms to
make it better
and I'll just leave you with in doing
some exit polling in the 2009 minimal
elections we talked about 450 voters who
were coming out of the polls in Bamako
and and we asked to open it a question
you know why did you come out to vote
today and people said the vast majority
said we done so out of their patriotic
duty so i just wanted to sort of leave
those two contradictory images of how we
imagined formal electoral politics and
we can return to this later and we can
return to more what are people talking
about right now but I thought that's
what I contribute isn't opening my own
approach to this is from the discipline
of history and so I want to sort of
address I think what what Jamie ended
with we didn't plan it this way but it
it works well that why people feel this
patriotic duty and so this sense of
patriotism and the sense of sort of a
Malian nation and how that's been
expressed historically and how the
historic expression both kind of
responds to or shows the roots of some
of the some of the the roots of the
present crisis the even deeper
historical roots of the present crisis
and how it provides a political language
that's been used throughout the Third
Republic or maybe eight towards the end
of the third republic as well as right
now on facebook and twitter so first of
all I'd like to start out just with the
most basic reference to the past is the
name of the country itself is Molly
referencing this medieval empire in more
or less the same region of the country
right and this is not just the
showmanship of the independence era of
1960 that's the idea of Molly as some as
a political entity that's historically
rooted that has a history that goes back
well over a thousand years or so is
quite strong and so the best example of
this that I could find on the internet
this morning but I've been think about
this for a while is
this cover page for a book by mu Samara
who is one of the presidential
candidates that he has this this image
of Mansa Musa which if you've seen any
image of medieval Africa in your
elementary school or high school
textbooks this is this is sort of the
one image that you're going to see so
it's yes it's it's nice that he can sort
of use this picture his monster moose a
moose Amara they have the same name it's
certainly a symbol of political power
but a political power over what that the
long history of Mali that is discussed
within popular political rhetoric is one
of pluralistic States one that really
reaches back to the empires of Ghana of
male of song I that are you know 1,500
years old thousand years old 500 years
old and more recent political units the
domina empire on the Niger River some of
the some of the state's resisting French
imperial expansion in the 19th and even
the early 20th century are presented as
not just States not just sort of
pre-colonial States but states that
express their power over a very large
territory that expressed their power
over a great deal of time as well and
that were pluralistic not democratic in
the sense of elections or even sort of a
popular voice in the rule but states
that were very pluralistic that could do
that did do through what the Republic of
Mali has been trying to do for the past
50 years with its nation-building
project that is to say to create a sense
of a nation from a large and very
diverse population what's interesting
about Ghana Molly song i say goo and all
these empires really sort of it's a
history that's that's very well anchored
in the south of the country and the
north of the country
susannah described as not just this is
not just a recent phenomenon this is not
just a question of post-independence
secession war of secession or certainly
not just a result of what's happened in
Libya is that there isn't the same
history of integration that that that
can include the north and it's
problematic and people recognize this as
problematic but we see this when when
there's a very rich and well developed
and historically rooted history of
political pluralism of political
participation and of historical
legitimacy in the south of the country
that language that language is used so
often in electoral politics in speeches
in the way that that that even sort of
national politics is conceived is is
something that really kind of leans out
the north we see this actually this is
sort of a a Facebook page or whatever
groom called lay sofa de la rpublique
saw Sophie the sofa de la rpublique
this is this is a direct reference to
the soldiers of summary today this is a
reference to the the 19th century so
it's it's interesting there's there's
there's some voices here that like most
of most of what I've heard no one's
really coming out there's not a lot of
people who come out strongly for the
coup but the sofa de la rpublique is a
reference to sort of a military group
right soldiers themselves and trying to
sort of use this imagery that will allow
people to sometimes condemn sometimes
condone the the action of these soldiers
today but sort of have that language
almost I have that sort of historical
setting that makes it possible to talk
about politics as something that's not
just happening in the immediate present
but something that has
a meaning that goes into the past and
hopefully that sort of sets up its
importance for the long-term future so
you have sort of this and something else
I found on that same site this is one of
those posts that is not exactly
condoning the coup but certainly doesn't
condemn it and uses this image of
Liberty cigarettes which the name
Liberty sort of speaks to all of the
greatest aspirations that the that the
CNR dr is trying to appeal to but also
speaks to us with the legitimacy of the
first republic of molly this is one of
the first parastatal factories was to
make cigarettes and matches Molly and
mated Molly and smoked so you see sort
of this appeal not so much it's it's not
so much a question of sort of military
coup versus a republican government but
an appeal to an older idea of what
Malia's and one in this case that's very
much rooted in the republican politics
of the first republic the republican
politics of the 1960s and the republican
politics of sort of the independent
state of molly as has existed since
nineteen sixty but I think as dr. trauer
is going to explain in a little bit and
I think as Jamie and Susannah have have
mentioned as well dr. black and dr. wing
that electoral politics and that
Republican politics even was not as
accessible as it had hoped to the org it
was it needed to be as a plan to be
there's still a language within the
Republic of model in the Republican
model to make claims for democracy right
to make claims for greater political
participation in elections yes but
beyond elections
this is something you might have seen in
some of the images that are shown up on
TV and on the internet particularly
because yesterday was a national holiday
commemorating the end of this period
from March 22nd to march 26 1991 she's a
period of of a military crackdown on
pro-democracy activists in Bamako and 91
who are protesting sort of the single
party that had grown out of a military
dictatorship and it wasn't eager to
enact any political reforms to allow a
broader participation or broader series
of voice it's the same you know it's the
same date March 22nd and it's very
interesting to see sort of what has been
said or what was said yesterday and what
wasn't said yesterday in making this
connection between at 8a i'ma do to
monitor is coo of 1991 that the scene is
sort of the establishing point of Mali
and democracy today and the fact that
there's a military coup that happens
exactly 22 years after this bloody
crackdown on protesters so how how is
that being mobilized this is what
hopefully we can talk about a little bit
more because there's a lot coming out
even today from what was going on
yesterday but also how how do images
like this is there not just important
now they're not just important in the
context of the coup they're also
important in the context of non
electoral politics sort of economic
politics and this is going to mission to
our fourth speaker who comes from the
city of chi this is a similar monument
the materials a little bit different in
the city of chi which is a city known
for its connection to the railroad and
you see the same image of sort of a
woman on her knees with her hands up
miss teaching the heavens what has gone
wrong and more or less the same language
being used or marshall victim de la
cancion de chemin de fer de carne shia
this is a monument for
recognizing the sacrifices and
recognizing to the the grave attack
against people that came from the 2003
privatization or leasing to a private
company for a very long time of the
national railroad this is this is the
kind of corruption or at least is the
kind of misplaced priorities that you
here talking about today when people are
criticizing a thought a yes today after
the crew as well as years before the
coup but you can still use and people
still do use this language of the Third
Republic the language that should be
that you know that is so closely tied to
audit a this imagery this language is
still very is still very real and very
alive and this this is what I'm looking
for when i watch sort of video and film
and blog posts from from all I today so
now that we're a chi I'm going to turn
this over to kick or a trowel ray I'd
also just like to add one thing to his
introduction that I forgot earlier if he
looks familiar and you've seen the movie
Bamako he also played Shaka the main
character protagonist in in Bamako
Jean suite reserved a paske SE Kumar you
know Cassie on delivery Lima lamb tongue
dish he's very happy because it's an
opportunity for two I don't know how to
put it but to inform the misinformed I
guess I've at Porterville revenue road
am NOT conception the Secchia existing
O'Malley a veritable man yup I the
democracy omani cassava dear Oh namion
plus de su t key permit that's where in
democracy may suzuki non pas functioning
this gives us sort of an opportunity
here to look at what we had expected
what everyone sort of talks about when
we talk about Malian democracy that what
should have been in Mali but wasn't that
they had put in place all of the
machinery necessary for democracy yet it
did not come about oh sorry dear loser
bon rien camp or party politic predators
and particulate eek des Association las
cosas de Saville Jana Blue Demon less
OMG can't ohta revenue politic esker
c'est pour faire de la poltica concrete
do some party lubrication lagi
so what we have here in Mali or what we
had in Mali was 200 political parties
there's 10,000 different
non-governmental association national
non-governmental associations or social
civil civil society associations and how
many sort of national internationals
with NGOs on the ground and this is now
I've lost my train of life because I
januvia party political deal because
this one particular chip rockefeller
political MonaVie talk with 200
political parties how can you have a
functioning electoral system based on
political parties should what dear
kuzushi abdoun a looky-loo la condition
qm / me ah regime defer den stylistic is
no happily look on some fish and this
creates the conditions that allow the
people in power to establish a regime
known as a regime or a system of
consensus politics yah Mon avika
consists a two-sample mardonius dr.
politic Keystone down loser du pouvoir
Susur V dole opposition pour avoir des
moines que le suit numba so in my
reading of this this is something that
allows the people in power to share a
political power but also to share of
material wealth with people who are
participating in this game to have to
participate and not sort of engage in a
level of criticism or take the sides of
people who don't have a voice in the
system suse Africa for example day
delivery else us on develop a poor de
true ear sakira steadily economy
national for example Brendan Oct la
privatization leishman fair a tool
leticia economic Epis a par la mme SI
les a result of a conscience Cassini
deeper in one shoes so this is a way
that really the national economy has
been destroyed and he makes reference to
the railroad that I mentioned in my talk
that so this was a backbone for the
national economy and it was privatized
even though so many people said that
this is not a good idea because so much
of what is moved through the country is
moved through the railroad so CR / me
you see a shock on Kevin car quiero par
de cerrar el exploitation said position
osita dear la corruption Lou to sort of
occasion and Bucca do prove he did the
supposition so everyone who had their
own little neighborhood of power their
own place for they're in charge they
were they had this opportunity to stay
where they weren't aware they were and
manage and profit from this and this is
what we call corruption that they're
taking advantage of their own local
power networks NC population alaba's
voix de su skin swamp except of dew
point even la la la dices men sucia
couvert par lamont eau de la del
Infiniti SF echo le population cds on
Lorien fair contr sabes que yo this
example ki aman trikha the schuster a
gravity-fed menace to turn and possibly
you wonder prejudice so people were
perfectly aware of what was going on and
saw what was happening and knew that it
was it wasn't right and it was illegal
but they also saw that the people who
are carrying this carrying out these
activities who were involved in this
corruption were covered with sort of a
cloak of invincibility and that they
couldn't bring through the power of law
power of the state to act against them
junipa deal could duel monster khushi SE
passe used i don't want to say that
everyone everyone
acting in his ways that's that's that's
not fair me circuses s a given lucha
contra sola so SI l'objet to the civvies
our betrayal but those people who see
what's going on and organized in
opposition read and speak out against it
are caught up in the in device of the
system that that is acting it that will
comes down on them suse abre por su
kanaval la classe politic may you see da
la 67 dallas indika come to sample
mandala population edition key' onto new
loccent in l4d founder leveller kiss on
cell largely a do not repeat blood so
there are people in the product class
there are people in civil society there
are people in in the trade unions who do
see their role and do act in this role
as defending the values of the Republic
and of the of the political system as it
should be me if we deal come on voir
Rosalita and carita crema en paz savvy
Dukas a fortune on papi and influency
laser fairly public so when we see a
coup de tat like we have just seen and
we arrived at the impasse that we've
arrived at this is proving that these
civil society forces do not actually or
disable society actors do not have the
force of the authority that that they
should ii mother islam say force son of
a Blee rien qui parle avec la la regla a
Pluto la confinement you Prince do you
curl debtor integra a defender valor ki
serve to one so one of the reason the
reason why this civil society after
these actions for the Republic have been
so weak is
because they recognize that the rules of
the game are really are a width and
decided by the people in power at the
moment she would literally kill shoes
para para la situacin do you know and I
want to say something now about the
situation in the North my perception
this set situation cycle say in in an
aspect fragile de las Oct key explorer t
a shock for cool Lucas represent to poo
legs actor around ad phenomena so this
is a situation that is very delicate and
has been and it's and it's something
that is exploited throughout the recent
history by political actors when they
feel the need to exploit it lundy Zarda
mallu soo guan yu GT echo Lenore a rere
a pleaser lyrical RSVP one of the most
commonly used arguments is that the
north is not just backwards that it is
the most backwards region of the country
for Monza said la Poudre you Pascal
contraband inert sector Anwar develop
problems do development Kim Sun pawan
graphic uno melon way Lissie poor
defenders Lord wha-la oceans Monday good
condition V nap alarm so for me that's
just sort of a smokescreen that there
are other regions of the country that
are just as equally far from from from
from development or so far from from how
and they don't use the same the same
political language they don't make the
same arguments by by military force and
they don't succeed I'm fed come to
regard le moyen qet I mean you know if
you look at the at the money that's
that's been sent to the north Luke is
you say cycle
ankle example the lock operation Mollie
Libby IT fundamental ma angry chillin oh
and that this long history of
cooperation between Molly and Libya is
fundamentally anchored in the question
of the north II recessions there's a
nexus on this i teach dizzy pour juice
to ma matter des moines specific oh la
sua dizon por una vanilla Shep tell the
shamu so during the drought of the 1970s
that this relationship was used to send
material resources to North to relieve
some of the problems particularly
through the market of livestock and
particularly camels June connais pas du
secteur O'Malley ki-moon official
doulton des moines a continued said
period there is no other sector in in
Mali that benefited as much during this
period than the North Korean cool
associate Olivia Malian Kia ethically
deep deep analysis on this I mean a
regular ma minimum Casimir do the from
male cool sattva exclusive mapa Luna and
the male Libyan society partnership
spent 15 million Malian francs per year
William media sorry 15 billion yes Molly
and francs per year on this livestock's
game and other development projects in
the north it is sooo Mumma illusory
sushi for new Zebedee decedent a
PowerPoint 40 and the books are balanced
till Saturday meshach fois c'est plutt
prigioni production but every time that
there is a problem there's sort of this
pressure on the state for more more
materials ala don't go it won't pour moi
c'est si si si se fue my example month
last wicked ASEAN so you
sibility on diesel minority soon Laurie
cool paruparu development so for me this
is pure and simple political speculation
on the place of minority populations in
the country and their role and their
experience with development projects la
cuestin do lnternational I be a
unakite a dissertation Harley federal
law regime dafa Alicia entre la la la la
sortie son de la debe de mal en catal
be a vet for Dharma a definition and the
fall of Gaddafi's government in Libya
has brought us to a head once again now
that we see a number of Mullins
returning from Libya with arms new not
perception russula para por razones de
la Parisienne do regime second say de la
razn so our view of this with regards
to the state is this is an issue of
treason a school new president large
Emily Tampa knew your past executives
Armand panco person caffeine career
military ella Libby Napa Napa D frontier
cumin avec la MOLLE so the president of
Mali being a former soldier should be
aware of arms coming into his country
particularly from Libya which doesn't
share a border with Molly aloria DP kita
prison contact avec la le beak you
refused a causation or intrusive a pouco
es que cela malik Valerie's Larry venir
avec two layers owner kill foo so there
are other countries that are closer to
Libya that have refused so these people
coming back from the Libyan conflict and
yet in Mali they come back and are
welcomed with open arms
a preset Casey on you jewelry designer
Cherie de la fasala put it on down to
ski swap and then this is managed and
absolutely mismanaged fashion jewelry
mercy and not another kitchen thank you
I wait for your questions I'm supposed
to be a moderator but I was asked to
make a statement so I wrote about two
pages a comment in an attempt to put
Molly in a kind of global context much
of what I'm going to be saying has been
said but sometimes there is a virtue to
repetition if for no other reason then
for for a retention I think I want to
begin with especially the presentation
on the Mali Empire gana Empire i want to
remind you of a song by salif keita
called Ojo fama you know you are right
King and and the song basically goes on
to praise the kings of Malian or the
trauma can't raise the Sun Gate Akitas
reverse the jerez of King Gita you right
you right but today the time when we
used to stop arrest of a powerful man
has passed you know you can rest on your
laurels of kings but that time has past
months I mean I don't be a it's a ido yo
fam i don't know if you know that song
yeah so he praises you brings up you
your pride and all of this but this a
bad time has passed you know so you are
right but the time has passed now work
is what counts you work work is what
counts and consensus is what counts and
so on and I think that song is very
important for our time at
it's a salif keita song and it's called
Eagle Pharma so I think he goes also
with your presentation on you know
because this whole pride thing has to go
so let me read quickly I am I editorial
my polemical diatribes the criminal and
chaotic situation Molly today is a
direct result of NATO's intervention in
Libya to overthrow Gaddafi in the wake
of the Arab Spring many of us were in
favor of removing Mahama Qaddafi from
power to open another door to the winds
of democracy blowing in the region most
importantly we wanted to see an end to
the humanitarian disaster provoked by
the regime in tripoli by throwing both
fools of african immigrants to the sea
and to stop the impending massacre of
the population of bent benghazi
threatened by the narcoleptic dictator
at that time President Obama and Sarkozy
with the help of France's media savvy
and tell actual burner ari levy known as
bare shell has concocted a narrative
well packaged for consumption in which
the Libyan strong man like Saddam
Hussein and Hitler was described as
capable of committing unprecedented
crimes against humanity and the National
Transitional Council has only motivated
by the passion for democracy thus the
invasion of Libya was clinically
executed from the air by NATO planes to
the greatest relief of the majority of
the United Nation members and all those
who believe that a democratic change in
the Arab world in general and Libya in
particular will safeguard the world
against terrorism gender inequality and
dissemination and racism against blacks
today I am now writing about these
cliches races and Islamophobic sound
bites that
are often embedded in narratives whose
true motives Trump democracy and
humanitarian concerns for called
neoliberal economic plans how else would
one explain the situation of O'Malley
defenseless with its archaic tanks and
machine guns pitted against the soldiers
of the former Qaddafi army and the
sophisticated weaponry as the Malian
army retreats the rebel army moves in
one town after another cutting the
throats of soldiers and civilian
populations destroying everything in
their way and creating panic among the
population of Gao and Timbuktu which lie
ahead of them more than 200,000 civilian
have fled these towns and nomadic
settlements to seek to seek refuge in
neighbouring countries such as
Mauritania burkina faso Algeria and
measure the population of a girl hug
gundam and pestle it in northern Mali
have suffered the heretic crimes that
NATO forces had prevented Qadhafi forces
from committing in Benghazi additionally
northern Mali after the fall of Timbuktu
and guru will soon become an untalented
had heaven for radical Islamist groups
such as acne which is a branch of
al-qaeda and sardine which is another
Islamic group all intent on imposing the
Sharia law from Algeria to Mali
Mauritania Niger Nigeria Chad and Sudan
another major threat to the region is
the drug trade transiting in the sahara
desert desert on its way to Spain France
and Italy the defeat of the Malian army
and enough has created national
discontent with a weakened and
humiliated regime in Bamako that was
considered by many as one of the Deacons
of democracy in West Africa president
amadou toumani toure or known as a TT
has now been exposed
as a weak leader always seeking
consensus and never acting decisively to
combat corruption or to draw the line on
how far he was willing to give him to
the demands of death were eggs in the
North attitude was also accused of
undermining the democratic institution
by always caving in to the demands of
demagogue ish demagogic religious
leaders who were opposed in the name of
Islam and tradition to the
constitutional amendment back for
equality between men and women faced
with this general discontent wounded
pride and anger directed at the
president a hunter made up of junior
officers has seized power like bank
robbers taking advantage of it black out
to put their plan into execution the
coup seems more ironic not to say
ridiculous given that on the one hand
the disarray in Bamako the capital city
sends a strong signal to the rebels that
they are winning the war on the other
hand the presidential election are only
one month away an attitude had reached
the end of his last term in office as
high as hard as it is to take a good
data seriously nowadays in Africa even
in Africa the silence of Obama Sarkozy
and bare shell over Qadhafi's former
soldiers in northern Mali side-by-side
with members of al-qaeda acme and
sardine and narco-traffickers seems even
more and fatima fathomable to me the
fact that Qadhafi's former intelligence
chief abdullah al sanusi some of you
have seen in the news was recently
arrested with the Malian passport in
Mauritania is an indication that NATO
and the lydian national transitional
council did not complete the job in
Libya they just deteriorated it and made
it the problem for Molly today and soon
for night nigga
Tania and Nigeria it is a desert view of
another American and NATO botched job
with which we're all familiar some would
even say that it is the logic of
neoliberalism follow the money and don't
get bogged down with moral imperatives
now with the coup d'etat in full gear
and the radical religious groups in
control of the North the useful sir the
usual suspects are lining up with the
condemnation of the group they desire
for a peaceful negotiation of the
conflict in the north and they return to
constitutional order in Mali we're
familiar with this narrative to from the
UN the US the EU and the AU likewise no
one would be surprised if they fell on
deaf ears among the junta in Bamako and
the Qaeda and Acme in the north the
population in Bamako and elsewhere are
in shock and the only reaction so far
has been to take cover and protect their
properties cars and goods from the
soldiers turned looters it is clear
therefore that the Malians discontent
with the democratically elected
president is not matched by a show of
support for the coup makers in fact it
has been hard for many Malians who had
thought that the country had gone past
an army takeover of power to wake up for
the last three days five days now and
find that the country has regressed more
than 20 years back so I dare predict the
imminent collapse of this coup like the
end of a nightmare that people have
awoken from by next week if civil
servants in Mali stay at home and
refused to collaborate with the hunter
and if the neighboring country shut the
doors to members and emissaries of the
imposters then I do not think that it
would last long on the contrary as I see
them retreating today Barack soon after
they have finished loot
public and private properties as for the
northern question and and this is really
the most contentious one and i will take
exceptions with my colleague at the
correct ryori because when he traveled
in africa as i have done it in a you go
from algeria you go to burkina faso you
go tunisia nigeria all the way to
cameroon ec young twilight kids begging
in the streets ghana anywhere you go so
there must be a failure of something no
matter how much money to spend maybe the
money is not being spent well i don't
know but personally I feel very bad when
I see em to RX begging sweet corners
everywhere in africa and there's a
worried from this I'm from Mali you know
and they're begging such that there is
something wrong and this has been 50
years and has been like that so that the
Torak question is important yes I agree
with your money has been put in there
but maybe something needs to be done
whatever that is we that's what we need
to think seriously about because when
you ask Marlins from the south those
basically said well they lazy they don't
work now that's what white people say
about us they say we're lazy we don't
work and now we're saying that to the
products so we need to look at it more
seriously because I mean I'm from the
south but this is what they say and I
stop here because of all people didn't
go too long so I just stop here thank
you let me just make it clear for those
people who are not familiar with echo s
is the West African regional economic
association and they meeting today and i
think is the most important meeting the
outcome of the meeting if they are they
will condemn the cool anyway so if they
condemn me in a soft leg that's one
signal if they condemn it firmly these
people are gone so depends on what
they're going to say because in a week
or two
they will have no money to pay the civil
servants a little weak you know this was
a in Rome on today and all the places
problem about this is not about
expertise is by reading Twitter and the
news if I can just follow up on that
that I think absolutely that one of the
things that this hunter is facing is the
complete isolation I mean everybody has
come out against it and what I had read
prior to the ecowas meeting was talk of
I mean how forceful a response will this
be will will this even be I mean I've
read would this even be a military
response i don't i don't know one thing
i think is interesting that i also read
is that the the MNLA the movement
nacional de votacin de soie that's the
Tuareg group has said immediately post
the coup they don't want to negotiate
with these coup people they want to
negotiate with a legitimate government
that's internationally recognized so you
know there any progress that might be
made in terms of actually talking having
some sort of dialogue to resolve this
crisis is you know that that and clearly
the coup leaders are talking it's purely
about force it is about it is about the
securitisation through force of the
north and and and so let's leave it at
that
casa sua soaked on a bellicose k sosua
Anita quienes hora por bilateral avec la
MOLLE is only true a defender leg r
impressive nasi kerabu Jory poor Emily
es on purple sakuno sumtin sin city as
one critic Dalek el y nepali oh poor
Lisa Tazio L regime katom be a montre le
limit de campinas sajan do drape a purdy
terv solution oh jordu e esse e doblo
que les affair la sua la value function
minus zafar enter por su bei ATT purezza
family DOMA a venir per se faire men SE
serait krea in situatio humanitarian
sajid but okay to sum up a little bit in
English that that it's it's a question
for echo us and it's a question for
bilateral agreements that certainly yes
other countries and regional
institutions have their own interests in
the political future of Mali but the
question is also there's this very
important question to ask about what the
results of this will be in Mali itself
that there's that there's a threat of a
very serious humanitarian crisis to that
that is on the heels of this political
crisis that were now living through la
reality echo Lou a doof on common app
Elsa regime a furphy de la ralit a
common veg dear ya que consiste  la
famine kiss n esta ley de la saison
pleader mia zapata lucy rosa vimla
Susteren so first of all the now-defunct
government of a telltale hell
not been concerned with the with with of
what has gone since what's gone on in
the environment and in the country as
far as the politics of drought and
famine since the last rainy season or
last planting season some quanti could
impress deus allah ya la situacin you
nor gate imagery and of course the
situation in North is very poorly
managed lot regime Casey own sake oh
yeah in reality consists of FATCA down
low p/e on napa crelli condition y
function ma de l'cole de la sant du
travail pratik mallu PE a colon p on
chemo and the third the third issue is
that the state itself is not functioning
correctly that that the schools that the
way that that that work and and and so
the labor market is managed it's all
rotten from the court that the state
does not work e once you say the Sun
team uncle Lou Malian William ah and I
know what the average Molly and some
things about this don't click prishel
exterior / sector see Mellie Malian
supra do moinho chosen person except
Appa so close to addicted like Syria so
the foreign interests can certainly say
what they have to say but it's also very
true that that a majority of Mullins
perhaps sixty percent are not going to
accept terms being dictated from outside
of the country donc la joie Umbra
defense tally agency paseo de la koo
international onshore tira grandi so I'm
worried about a very sort of
heavy-handed response being developed
outside of the country and that this is
not going to help democracy return to
Molly yeah these are the Air Force kiss
organ is sooo lieutenant and there's
already two forces gathering
for me they indicate more the failure of
nation-state in Africa molly is not
exceptional in this in every single
statement here Molly is no worse than
Burkina Faso than measure than Senegal
than many of these places they know the
nation-state the very poor I just said
if they if US cuts the aid of France
cuts the copper ASEAN the end they will
not be able to pay for the salaries in
Mali or broken or any of these places
Somali is not exceptional at all it
seems to me there for that we should
focus on the criminality of the hunter
that brought about this I don't think
the maitre c is really what is on trial
here you know I think to criticize the
Micra see or to criticize Outsiders for
intervening is one way of supporting the
cuda time in my opinion here because I
don't see Molly Herrick a better
situation democratically Senegalese
actually invited attitude now I've never
received anything from a TT I don't have
anything to do a heart attack NYU pays
my salary I'm very independent man so
don't take me so I take his concerns you
said it very clearly was a problem
people did not think that he was a
strong man but even that is coming from
this Malian character of being a man you
gotta do this you gotta be decisive more
than an accusation of democracy for me
so in a to put democracy on trial or to
put to make Molly exceptional really
doesn't work much for me in
understanding the crisis things are
evolving so fast it's hard to get a
sense of I mean as it's been said before
this is in part a state building issue
and these are complicated really
difficult questions and i think it is
essential that the voice come from the
molly people and also the diaspora being
part of that this is minor and maybe not
as good as like what you could bring to
a protest but i think that the diaspora
has played an amazing role on the
twitter and facebook and skyping and has
facilitated communication about what's
going on in different places I mean
that's certainly who I've turned to to
get my information and it I mean it
seems minor but I i think that flow of
information coming from those voices and
not just international press reports
have really helped flesh out the story
of what's going on yeah i mean i think
nation states with the exception of
places like Nigeria which we all know is
chaotic nation states are not that
viable in Africa really they're so small
and so fragile the d aspirant mean my
opinion and I've been writing about this
the best investment of their politics
and time is to link up with the
african-american community here and have
the african-american community fight for
them in DC with the black lobby and the
friends of Mali but to wait for a coup
and suddenly there are the money to
lobby in Washington I mean Nigeria can
do that original community can do it or
african-americans but really yes I feel
really sorry for Molly now but if things
have gone wrong in Senegal would be
talking the same when things almost went
wrong so it's because this nations are
so fragile and it is so weak they just
put them there so they can vote in the
United Nation and with France or with
the Soviet Union I don't think we viable
that's why when we talk about the
northern question it's not just the
northern question its Molly Molly as a
whole you know and I'm 100-percent
Malian speak three languages of Mali so
but I don't think it's viable unless we
do something with my neighbors and we're
not gonna do that so we'll be there
forever we need to be Molly need to be
with senega Guinea they speak the same
languages and when he said that they
think you're crazy because frankly there
haven't been too many
sudden and tragic opportunities to make
a political statement like that in the
past 20 years one of the reasons why the
mall in diaspora is so large here is
that it's fairly easy making money with
that's greatly qualified but it's fairly
easy to move between Molly and the
United States of two very friendly
nations and I don't and I don't think
unlike some other countries certainly
there's not a network of political
refugees in the Diaspora here as as
there might be from other places but
yeah I think I think that there is a
great deal of political legitimacy that
can be drawn from the connections that
are made outside of Mali as well because
molly is not just a territorial entity
that this is what that long history is
and this is what in response briefly to
sort of your counsel to move away from
mozza Musa and other Kings yeah that but
I think that's what's going on it's not
it's not ego fama it's a Joe a Joe Oh
Joe Faso down ah that that the history
of pluralism is becoming a democratic
history that's being told and one that's
being told around the world